bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre émission
rugby l'équipe senior de versailles
réalisé la bonne opération de cette 13e
journée de fédérale 3 les joueurs de la
cité royale se sont imposés à 20,16
contre pithiviers les détails dans ce
magazine basket féminin le
chesnay-versailles temps tête du
championnat de nationale 3 avec trois
points d'avancé sur le 2e ruaudin pour
recevront dans quelques instants sur ce
plateau les joueuses julie femmes et
perrine chollon athlétisme la deuxième
édition du meeting en salle de
versailles était organisée ce samedi au
stade de porchefontaine le rendez-vous a
été créé pour permettre aux athlètes du
département de s'affronter pendant la
période hivernale reportage à suivre
et puis l'essentiel de l'actualité
sportive du département nous parlerons
notamment du trail des villes royales et
une course à pied en pleine nature qui
s'est déroulé entre le château de
versailles et le château de rambouillet
on commence donc ce magazine par du
rugby l'équipe senior de versailles peut
toujours espérer se maintenir en
fédérale 3 les joueurs de baptiste
gouache se sont imposés à domicile à
20,16 contre pithiviers lors de la 13e
journée du championnat
le montage est signée à romain respini
l'équipe seniors du rugby club de verser
a réalisé la bonne opération de cette
13e journée de fédérale 3 à la lutte
pour le maintien les bleus ont décroché
une précieuse victoire à 2006 ce
dimanche contre pithiviers l'équipe qui
lutte également pour ne pas descendre le
score à la fin ça on va dire que c'est
une belle victoire parce que l'état
rachète des tripes
c'était un adversaire finalement que
s'est avéré difficile avec un jeu au
pied très très très généreux
c'était compliqué on marque on marque
sur le premier c'était dur à voile après
on marque un deuxième et là on les
enfonce qu'on va pas le bonus mais au
moins on fait un bon match c'est mérité
en tout cas pour toute l'équipe
les coaches damien verstraete a été l'un
des hommes clés de la rencontre de
retour dans le groupe pour cette
deuxième partie de saison après six mois
passés dans le sud de la france à
tournefeuille le versailles et formé au
club apporte stabilité dans les phases
offensives
tu voulais jouer avec les copains
c'était ça fait plaisir de revenir voilà
c'est mes potes d'enfance donc que c est
peu dire de gagnants sont aujourd'hui
c'est un enfant du club et quand on voit
un enfant du club qui revient chez nous
et qu à la hargne à ce point pour sortir
le club des difficultés si le plus
belles choses qu'on puisse dire quand on
est un club formateur on est très
contents de la voir ça un retour un
retour très satisfaisant pour l'équipe
pour le groupe
versailles pointe désormais à un point
du premier non relégable
une victoire le dimanche 28 février
contre courbevoie pourrait permettre aux
joueurs de la cité royale de se
rapprocher du maintien
l'histoire continue et la saison n'est
pas finie
après le rugby on passe au basket on
continue ce magazine à part du basket le
chesnay-versailles temps tête du
championnat de nationale 3 et 3 points
d'avancé sur le deuxième ruaudin avec un
bilan de 15 victoires en 16 matches
disputés depuis le début de la saison
pour décrypter les bons résultats du
club nous recevons sur ce plateau la
capitaine julie femmes et la pivot
perrine chanlon bonsoir alors quand on
analyse votre pourcentage de victoires
on peut dire que la saison est
exceptionnel quasiment 100% victoire
quasiment 100% après on a eu au mois
d'octobre en revers à ruaudin
malheureusement
il est possible que soit l'équipe qui
partent avec nous en play-offs donc on
dans ces cas-là on partira une victoire
une défaite mais autrement on peut dire
que c'est quasiment un sans faute et
c'est trop facile cette saison pour pour
vous ah non on peut jamais dire qu'une
saison est trop facile c'est trop forte
malheureusement on ne peut pas le dire
comme ça au vu des résultats
effectivement on est un petit peu au
dessus sur la poule
mais comme l'a dit julie on a subi un
revers à ruaudin choristes de le garder
en fait pour pour notre phase de play
off
et pourquoi l'équipe fonctionne aussi
bien cette saison contrairement par
exemple à la saison dernière allez y ait
eu quand même un remaniement de l'équipe
à l'intersaison il ya eu une descente de
division donc on se retrouve pas dans la
même division on est actuellement
nationale 3 l'équipe fonctionne bien
parce qu'on on travaille aussi à
l'entraînement donc c'est le fruit de
notre travail qui qui se retrouvent dans
le résultat de nos matches et faut pas
se mentir l'équipe a été aussi
construite pour bien fonctionner cette
saison vous avez le niveau vraiment la
nationale 2 vous avez une équipe de
nationale 2 en ce moment sur le papier
oui
après c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que
ça le niveau est pas le même les
exigences sont pas les mêmes
la vitesse de jeu et pas la même donc
non on a fait en sorte de construire
cette équipe pour essayer de monter le
plus facilement possible mais c'est pas
on peut pas vraiment dire qu'une équipe
à tel ou tel niveau
c'est pour l'instant on peut dire qu'on
est au dessus du niveau de la nationale
3 sur les résultats ce qui peut pas dire
que sur le terrain des fois on n'est pas
en manque de concentration des fois il
ya beaucoup de travail derrière pour
progresser de semaine en semaine on se
repose jamais sur nos lauriers ou en se
disant bon bah c'est bon on est premiers
nous c'est pas ça qu'on recherche
sinon on fait pas du sport ça suffit pas
de game il faut gagner toujours avec la
manière en essayant de progresser et
d'améliorer les choses
la force de cette équipe et c'est
peut-être également l'ambiance il y a
une très bonne ambiance cette équipe oui
très bonne ambiance après si c'est vrai
que le bon esprit qui porte le coeur
pour la plupart on se connaissait depuis
déjà plusieurs années
donc on s'est retrouvés c'était pas
vraiment
un hasard de jouer ensemble cette année
donc forcément la cohésion était plus
facile à faire
de par le fait qu'on se connaissait
depuis plusieurs années qu'on avait déjà
joué ensemble et après les nouvelles
choses qu'on a intégré était tout de
même état d'esprit
voilà l'objectif c'était la montée et on
sait tout mis ça dans la tête et des
moyens pour y arriver
comment on gère une série de deux
victoires comme celle là il n'y a pas un
risque peut-être de déconcentration dans
l'équipe et me suis justement bien se
garder sous pression à chaque match oui
le coach est là pour nous le rappeler en
effectivement on a une série de
victoires qui n'ont pas toujours été
acquise dès la première minute du match
notamment par exemple un match à sannois
où l'on gagne à la dernière seconde
donc on est on est remise en question
toutes les semaines et le coach nous le
rappelle bien dès le premier
entraînement de la semaine en faisant le
bilan du match mais entre guillemets en
oubliant ce match là et on passe au
suivant pour se remettre dedans re
travailler toute la semaine pour pouvoir
gagner le suivant on prend vraiment les
matches un par un et ça nous permet de
de recommencer hambourg commencer la seo
de la saison à zéro tous les week-ends
en tout cas vous pouvez vous ne pouvez
plus vous cacher maintenant c'est sûr
qu'après l'objectif de cette première à
l'asie quasiment a vaincu vous pouvez
plus vous cacher l'objectif était déjà
été déjà défini en début de saison nous
sommes au sein de l'équipe au sein du
club on savait que c'était la volonté de
remonter en nationale 2 on a les
résultats qui suivent
effectivement maintenant chaque équipe
qui qui nous reçoit ou qui vient chez
nous a envie de nous battre parce que
oui on a l'objectif de monter et on est
l'ogre à l'ogre à abattre et quels sont
vos principaux adversaires sur cette fin
de saison
vous même peut-être c'est ça c'est
évident quand on est premier
comme comme le disent et perrine les
toutes les équipes viennent pour battre
le premier donc c'est difficile ça met
une certaine pression parce que chaque
équipe se dit bon on n'a rien à perdre
alors que nous on a tout à perdre tout
laisse donc ça c'est pas évident mais
on prend vraiment les équipes avec
beaucoup de sérieux
on se dit pas one ou c'est bon on est au
dessus parce que c'est là où l'argent je
sais pas de danger donc on est vraiment
très concentré là dessus maintenant
c'est que toutes les équipes qui nous
restent à jouer sont en dessous de nous
voir battable au milieu de tableau donc
il faut rester très concentré pour sur
touba ne pas avoir un revers qui qui
fera un peu tache sur notre saison ce
serait dommage et puis il faut se donner
confiance parce que maintenant pour nous
la saison 1 démarre maintenant vous avez
rien les play-offs et ça c'est
maintenant qu'il faut qu'il faut
engranger de la confiance la sérénité
pour arriver à 100 % donc c'est un match
ce week-end prochain contre le 4e
douvres c'est une équipe que vous
connaissez bien
on les connaît bien vu que pour nous
versailles ça fait bien longtemps qu'on
était
et pas en nationale 3 donc on les
connaît vinko prend toujours des
informations entraîneur voilà notre
entraîneur prend toujours des
informations à droite à gauche récupère
quand il ne peut des vidéos
les scoreuses des équipes adverses donc
on essaie de préparer au mieux sa après
on sait que c'est des équipes où ça va
vite c'est petit c'est tonique c'est
agressif
nous on sait ce qu'on a à faire mais
faut surtout joué comme nous on sait le
faire
c'est c'est vraiment nous les mettre
dans dans le jeu si on fait ce qu'il a à
faire
tous deux bien se passer vous pouvez
vous permettre un revers ce week end où
il faut quand même viser le sans faute
alors effectivement si on regarde
mathématiquement on est plutôt à l'aise
dans le classement et on a quelques
points d'avance donc on pourrait se
permettre un revers après c'est vraiment
pas notre politique c'est pas notre
philosophie
donc on
on essaiera de par en avoir et
d'engranger des victoires ça nous fera
du bien pour la suite pour se préparer
justement aux matches couperets qui
auront lieu en play-offs où là on n'aura
que quatre matches et pas le droit à
l'erreur
merci à toutes les deux être passé sur
ce plateau bon courage pour ce match
contre douves après le basket on our une
page hacker tisme la deuxième édition du
meeting en salle de versailles était
d'organiser à ce samedi au stade de
porchefontaine le rendez-vous a été créé
pour permettre aux athlètes du
département de s'affronter pendant la
période hivernale florennes parfait à
pour les images du saut à la perche de
la course en indoor le deuxième meeting
en salle de versailles était programmé
ce samedi au stade de porchefontaine
dans la cité royale
cet événement exclusivement réservé aux
yvelinois est l'unique rendez vous
inscrit au calendrier hivernal du
département et des palaces et de
meetings dans les yvelines est justement
de mes athlètes étaient un peu en
demande de compétition pour pouvoir
justement soulevé durée entre eux et
donc on a pu créer ce meeting parce
qu'on a une belle halle d'athlétisme des
entraîneurs à disposition donc toutes
les conditions étaient réunies justement
pour créer ce mythe est cette année
au total plus de 100 athlètes d'une
dizaine de clubs du département ont
participé à l'événement il ya de tout
niveau des athlètes vraiment du benjamin
qui n'a jamais fait de compétition
justement aux athlètes qui est un des
compétitions nationales pour les
benjamins et les minimes la compétition
faisait figure de répétition générale
avant la finale départementale programmé
dans un mois aux bonnes dans le val
d'oise pour les cadets les juniors ce
meeting versailles a été l'ultime rendez
vous en salle de la saison
l'objectif de l'événement était avant
tout de tester ses performances
personnelles sans aucune pression c'est
bien de se préparer en faisant des
centaines de petites compétitions comme
ça qui font une sorte d'entraînement
avec d'autres personnes qui n'y sont
contre eux
ça permet d'être plus relax c'est pas
une compétition à haut niveau s'il n'y a
pas d'enjeu les france y sont passés si
on va en mode entraînement en fait donc
c'est vraiment cool
vu le succès rencontré cette année une
troisième édition devrait être organisée
en 2017
l'étoile sportive de trappes est dans
une bonne dynamique le club coaché par
arnaud mbc est actuellement la troisième
place du classement à un petit point du
deuxième sarcelles pour nous parler du
club nous recevons sur ce bateau le
président mustapha larbaoui et le coach
arnaud et bizi bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous avez connu une petite baisse
de régime
arnaud au mois de novembre décembre là
depuis 2016 tout va pour le mieux on
essaie de dire tout à fait un bond suite
au drame qu'on a connu avec le décès de
notre chère à mios samba donc un petit
coup de mou depuis on a pu se ressaisir
et pourront partir plus sereinement
quand ça a vraiment touché le club plus
qu'un club nouvelles quêtes et c'est
très affecté quand on joue du cou on
essaie de repartir en fait c'est pour se
remobiliser et puis d'euros pour un peu
de force en face au projet commun que
deux clubs à mustapha rond on voit
l'image
ouais c'est surtout que je vois samba
arnaud a raison c'est pas que le club
pour le coup c'est toute la ville mais
en l'occurrence ça a été ça a été un
coup très compliqué à gérer en interne
mais tous les jours le dirai il faut que
le football continue comme la vie doit
continuer et en l'occurrence c'est pour
ça qu'ils se sont accrochés parce que
par définition on aurait pu imaginer que
ça se fracasse beaucoup plus
et puis après ils les attentats derrière
donc on a eu beaucoup beaucoup de temps
de temps compliquée pour l'entraînement
perte de rythme etc
et puis un premier qui s'envolent
parlons également de houille qui
s'envole littéralement donc tout ça fait
que c'est très compliqué à gérer
là le challenger que nous étions au
départ c'est un peu émoussé et puis
finalement d'ailleurs ça me permet de
rendre hommage à tous les joueurs tous
les trappistes qui nous soutiennent et
combien compris ce qui s'était passé et
voilà on continue
je crois que c'est le maître mot depuis
maintenant des années on est là pour
construire un club ce club il se
construit avec toutes ces difficultés
avec ses joies ses peines
mais tout le monde est fondamentalement
sur l'idée que voilà on aura des
épreuves encore on en aura d'autres et
d'autres clubs ont traversé des épreuves
comme les nôtres malheureusement on
avance le décès de sang va peut être
soudé le groupe encore plus
effectivement dans la douleur la plus se
ressouder et puis repartir de l'avant
donc ma vie j'ai mon cas a dit le
président à l'idée se continue à
travailler puisque puis tout moment bon
on n'a pas d'autre choix que de faire ce
qu'on a à faire quelque chose au foot
du coup on essaie de la voter pour un
projet commun en fait par processeur
face à cette douleur il ya également un
deuxième bouleversements dans l'équipe
c'est la nommer votre nomination avoue
arnaud à telle ou telle équipe
les gens n'ont pas été trop perturbé
également par avoir ce changement
d'entraîneur ben on a eu un peu tout le
monde a vu que ce moment là que la
chance qu'ont actuellement ce que donc
je vais remplacer amos cas là aussi tout
à fait je rappelle donc moi je suis en
fait
hassar et du club quant à son métier il
faut reprendre en fait la continuté cet
été par an par notre salle donc comme je
connais très bien club satellite je
m'envole 1-1 face et pour moi en ce sens
où les joueurs me connaissent
il ya un matin de manière de fonctionner
qui est très simple qui consiste à dire
que nos jupes s'entraîne à part cela
ceux qui sont dans le projet de dans ce
projet là bas ils m'ont rejoint et puis
on avance comme ça mustapha il ya une
pâte
arnaud amisy on peut le dire il y a il y
a un vrai savoir faire une visite dans
le football en général on est ensemble
depuis 12 ans j'en ai toujours rêvé
sauf que les conditions ne s'y prêtait
pas du tout donc on n'a pas fait les
choses n'importe comment
on a vraiment construit les choses pas à
pas vous parlais tout à l'heure pas
encore un exemple de la construction sur
le long terme
arnaud depuis que je le connais je sais
c'est le manager qui nous faut dans ce
club et les 12 années qui sont passés
l'ont prouvé c'est l'artisan du club de
foot voilà quand ça va bien ce sont mes
troupes quand ça va mal ce n'est que moi
et je les assume et en l'occurrence ça
me permet de le dire aux téléspectateurs
c'est arnaud l'artisan du club voilà ce
qui me fait c'est pour ça que ça me fait
plaisir qu'il soit là aujourd'hui qu'on
le voit qu'on les écoute
j'en ai rêvé alors en réalité
j'en profite pour saluer également tous
ceux qui étaient là avant lui parce que
mochan n'a pas démérité justement il ya
un changement dans le projet de jeu
peut-être par rapport au match canardo
on a connu des vents mais après tout
voilà donc le 10 passant de symboles de
notre attaquant phare en fait deux
attaques
on joue différemment mais en fait c'est
même ce que moi je t'aime projeter
beaucoup son jeu vers l'avant vers
l'avant que j'ai la même résonance à
poney mais ces joueurs sont différents
genres du camp mais l'esprit est le même
encore une fois on change pâtir jeu on
voit notre ami me tiennent à l'antenne
également là il des biens par sauf qu'à
un moment donné c'est vraiment des
hommes qui rend compte des circonstances
et des circonstances qu'on a rencontrés
dans le club ce sont celles qu'on ait
évoqué de fleurs il y en a d'autres
d'autres qui sont voilà qui sont du même
ordre que ce qu'on peut entendre au psg
par exemple des petites frictions dans
les vestiaires des frictions sur les
terrains dans tous les terrains dans
tous les clubs il y en a et voilà c'est
la rencontre d'un homme et d'une mission
quasiment voilà donc c'est pas votre
chaîne qui des mérites c'est même par
les autres parce qu'on a eu d'autres
avant on a eu un turnover important
voilà sauf que il ya une ligne qui est
vraiment sur le coup sur lequel on veut
on prétend devoir rester et arnaud à mon
avis est celui qui va l'incarner
vous avez la deuxième différence de buts
du championnat derrière ou y
avec 24 buts marqués et seulement 11
buts encaissés
on peut dire que votre équipe est
équilibré tout à fait donc notre pauvre
effectivement c'est sa défense
on sait que défend collectivement fait
notre but après effectivement l'idée
c'est de pouvoir se projeter vers
l'avant pour essayer de marquer le plus
possible donc un équilibre qu on doit s
est trouvé entre de france on en parlait
il ya quelques instants ou y a dix
points d'avancé sur travail on peut dire
on peut dire que oui est imprenable
cette année c'est fini le championnat
est terminé pareil où la montée d'encore
envisageable équipe est imprenable
voilà des des événements extra-sportifs
qui peuvent arriver à tous
mais globalement oui il faut ils ont
leur destin en main quand nous on n'a
pas on est on est pour le coup on est on
est attaché quasiment la caravane
comprend deux fois pour le podium et
enfin la sculpture à ce jour c'est vous
êtes à un point du podium par l'ue à
prendre la deuxième place est majeur car
oui donc du coup ça très compliqué il
faut un sans faute tout à fait 100 fois
plus qu'à s'en tenir à sa femme dont on
parle de arnaud et les téléspectateurs
ne découpe pas un coup d'oeil à qui
chacun sa place dans une équipe de foot
j'ai des choses à faire moi aussi j'en
profite pour saluer donc la famille m
busy puisqu'on a également balthazar qui
joue dans l'équipe
la prod riquet qui fait un gros travail
de zlatan local voilà c'est ça donc on a
notre on a nos références no 6 voilà et
donc j'en profite pour saluer ce grand
nom du foot trappistes la famille bizi
comme je souligne de la même façon une
grande famille du foot attrape la
famille sissoko j'ai failli débaptiser
je les dis je crois l'avoir déjà
ici bientôt ça sera plus de rester mais
le cp et l'étoile 6 en cours de trappes
voilà des grandes familles de sportive
de footballeur et en même temps très
engagé au niveau du club de foot y en
ad'autres je pourrais pas tous les citer
mais globalement le rattrape
on aime le foot et une montre c'est à
dire qu'ils nous suivent dans nos
malheurs ils nous suivent dans nos
bonheurs et ils savent pourquoi on est
là et pourquoi on le fait il ya une
vraie vraie ambition une ambition voilà
modeste mais voilà avec un une
construction
merci à tous les deux dépassé ce plateau
bon courage pour la suite de la saison
on souhaite évidemment le meilleur pour
trappe percement pacéen dans l'essentiel
de l'actualité à sportive les
responsables du dossier des jeux
olympiques de 2024 ont présenté mercredi
dernier à la philharmonie de paris les
contours du projet parisien
parmi les sites retenu quatre sont dans
les yvelines les épreuves de cyclisme
sur route passeront par la vallée de
chevreuse et saint quentin en yvelines
le château de versailles va accueillir
les épreuves équestres et le pentathlon
le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines basée à
montillot bretonne organisera les
épreuves de cyclisme sur piste de bmx le
golf national de guyancourt recevra les
compétitions de golf une épreuve qui
reviendra dans le programme olympique
dès cet été à rio enfin à saint quentin
en yvelines organisera également les
compétitions de vtt sur la colline à
d'elancourt un site qui culmine à plus
de 230 mètres on écoute la réaction du
cycliste iny montrent un françois pervis
était évidemment ravi à de cette annonce
ce serait vraiment incroyable pour le
sport français en général surtout pour
pour nous et pour moi unis montrent un
avoir les jeux olympiques en france ça
voudrait dire que visiblement toutes les
épreuves du cyclisme serait dans la
région de montigné ses alentours
donc ce serait vraiment incroyable il ya
le feu devront couvert ça permettrait de
continuer dans le projet de
développement du cyclisme avoir tous à
proximité
ce serait se serait ce serait énorme
maintenant un mot de course à pied à
présent la première édition du trail des
villages roa des villes royales étaient
programmés à ce dimanche des coureurs se
sont élancés à 9h de la pièce d'eau des
suisses de versailles en direction du
château de rambouillet plus de mille
participants s'étaient inscrits pour ce
51 km les sportifs avaient la
possibilité de faire l'intégralité de la
course seul en l'équipe de troyes avec
un passage de témoin à chevreuse et
auffargis on écoute l'organisateur du
trail des villes royales à patrick
bonnaud on voulait organiser une course
qui était longue qui était en
ile-de-france en hiver alors qu'il n'y
en a pas encore et l'idée de promouvoir
un petit peu le tourisme le patrimoine
de la région entre le château de
versailles château de rambouillet est
venue il ya neuf mois et neuf mois après
comme un accouchement
on est haut sur la ligne de départ au
niveau des résultats nicolas dubaï a
terminé à course individuelle en 3h47
dans la catégorie relais la team pdm a
bouclé le périple en 3 heures 49 en
football l'équipe senior de versailles
devait recevoir bobigny à domicile ce
week-end à l'occasion de la 16e journée
du championnat de division honneur
le match a été finalement annulé les
joueurs de bobigny ne se sont pas
déplacés à cause d'un problème de bus
la ligue est de se réunir à cette
semaine pour statuer sur le sort de
cette rencontre on écoute l'entraîneur
de versailles youssef chibi où on veut
jouer les matches pour rejouer on
voulait remporter sur le terrain c'est
pas notre affaire de gagner les matchs
sur dans les commissions nos joueurs
étaient prêts pour jouer ce match-là il
rebondir suite à la défaite de créteil
la semaine d'avant bonjour dimanche pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir pratiquer pratiquer
remporté le match sur le terrain en
disputant nos chances sur le terrain et
pas avec les instants sur le match peut
être rejouer les versailles peuvent
également gagner le match sur tapis vert
à 3-0 on passe au badminton le tournoi à
régional seniors étaient organisées ce
week-end au centre sportif les pyramides
à voisins bretons ne plus de 340 joueurs
venus de 80 clubs et de 14 départements
se sont inscrits pour la compétition
on écoute l'organisateur campu sonne il
était au micro de florennes parfait
c'est un tournoi régional niveau
régional c'est à dire que juste après
mon gars du nom placé ensuite nous
départementales et régionales
donc après celle nationale 402 matchs
ont été organisées sur le week-end les
résultats sont à retrouver sur le site
internet du club de badminton de
voisins-le-bretonneux le en terminant
par du rugby plaisir n'en finit plus de
gagnants fédérale 3 les hommes de jean
miss se sont imposés 29 à 0 contre rueil
malmaison ce dimanche lors du 12e
victoire en 13 matches disputés au
classement en plaisir est toujours en
tête à égalité points et chris orangis à
cinq journées de la fin du championnat
la montée en fédérale 2 l'objectif du
club est en bonne voie
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 sport merci
d'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro très
belle soirée sur tv fil 78